ALAN SEALES: In "Cheech
is Not My Real Name,"
Cheech Marin writes
candidly about growing up
as a wise-cracking kid
in South Central LA,
resisting the draft, and his
chance meeting with Tommy
Chong, and how they formed one
of the most successful comedy
acts of all time.
Breaking up,
reuniting, and still
performing together to this day.
Please welcome to the
stage, Cheech Marin.
[APPLAUSE]
How you doing?
CHEECH MARIN: Very good.
Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Have a seat.
CHEECH MARIN: No, no.
Please.
Please, sit.
How's everybody today?
ALAN SEALES: So let's start
with some easy stuff here.
I actually like the
book cover itself.
It kind of symbolizes a
little something to me,
but I want to get your take
on what it actually means.
CHEECH MARIN: I was trying to
support the pinata industry.
ALAN SEALES: That was
what I was going to say.
CHEECH MARIN: It was good.
No, it was kind of
breaking up the old image
and seeing what's inside.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So your real name
actually is not Cheech.
CHEECH MARIN: No.
ALAN SEALES: Which is?
CHEECH MARIN: It's Richard.
Dick for short.
Although, not really.
But that's what they called me--
Cheech.
ALAN SEALES: Why did
you want to write
this book in the first place?
I mean, you're well-known
over many years
for many different
things, but why venture
into the author territory?
CHEECH MARIN: Money.
They offered me a lot
of money to do it.
OK.
That's the truth.
I was doing an art
talk in San Diego,
and there was a literary
agent in the audience.
She says, these
stories are great.
You've got to make
a book out of them.
So I said, can you
give me a deal?
Yeah, OK.
She did.
And so here we are.
ALAN SEALES: It was that easy?
Anyone can write a book?
CHEECH MARIN: Anybody, yeah.
As a matter of fact,
anybody can write a book.
Whether it's good
or not, who knows?
No.
And then it took a little while
to put all the stories together
and get a rhythm.
But I've been a writer
since I was little.
I've always wrote--
written-- wrotten.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
So you've wrotten.
CHEECH MARIN: I've wrotten.
ALAN SEALES: You
wrote a lot of stuff.
Is it writing if it's improv?
I guess it's recording.
CHEECH MARIN: Well, yeah.
I mean, if you do it
again, it's writing--
the same thing.
ALAN SEALES: How many times
did you write this book?
CHEECH MARIN: Oh, this book?
Not that many times.
Unlike some authors, I think
a lot before I put it down.
And so I was pretty satisfied.
And I had a
collaborator who would--
like a trainer, John Hassan.
He was, OK, we need
to go over this again.
But it was good.
ALAN SEALES: How long
did it take then?
CHEECH MARIN: The
actual writing part?
Maybe about six months.
ALAN SEALES: That's not bad.
CHEECH MARIN: No,
it was pretty good.
I write fast.
I'm on demand.
ALAN SEALES: But putting
the stories together,
did you have an outline?
Or how did you piece it
together in your muse there?
CHEECH MARIN: I knew that
I wanted to kind of tell
the whole life story, but I
didn't want to start it-- then
on this day I was born.
So I started it in medias
res, where I was in Canada.
And how did I get here?
How does a South Central LA-born
kid get to Calgary, Alberta
without corrosion?
And so I started there.
It was kind of this
existential quandrum
I was in because it was in
the middle of the Vietnam War.
And I was going to Canada
ostensibly to be a potter.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Yeah.
CHEECH MARIN: A potter.
And I did.
I made pottery professionally
for a couple of years.
ALAN SEALES: Well, you actually
start in the book before that.
You go into a little bit of
the South Central history.
But when you were
a kid in 1952, you
said you were on a radio show
called "The House Party" hosted
by Art Linkletter, right?
So what happened on that?
CHEECH MARIN: Well, it
was a radio program first.
And very shortly
thereafter, he put it on TV
called "Kids Say the
Darndest Things."
And he would try to get kids to
spill the beans on the family,
like my mother is pregnant.
My daddy doesn't know.
And so I was chosen.
I was in first grade, I believe.
I was chosen along with a
couple of other classmates
to get in a limo with every
candy and soda and cookie
available on Earth
and eat them all
before we got to the studio.
And then we put on the show.
ALAN SEALES: And you just
show up all hopped up?
CHEECH MARIN: They
opened the door
and like four sugar-laden
buzzing bees jumped out.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
I brought that up
because in the book
you mentioned that that's
where you got the acting bug.
CHEECH MARIN: Oh, yeah.
It was like the first time I
had ever been on something.
No, actually, I was in a
school play, a Christmas play.
And I played the kettle drum.
And we did "up on the
rooftops boom, boom, boom."
That was the kettle drum part.
And I was a little
kid, I mean, little.
I was always the littlest
guy in the class.
And for some reason
they assigned
me to do the kettle drum.
And you couldn't see me.
Every kid in this
little rendition
had a paper band with a
gold star on it like that.
And that's all you could see
of me is this little gold star.
And the hand would come out.
Boom, boom, boom.
And everybody thought
that was hilarious.
Hey, they're laughing.
I'm in show business.
All right.
It's a highlight for me.
ALAN SEALES: So your family
was in South Central LA.
How did your parents
end up there, like,
before you were born?
CHEECH MARIN: Oh, that's
where they grew up.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, really?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
That's where they grew up.
They were born in LA.
My grandparents were all
from Mexico, but my parents,
myself, all my children, all my
grandchildren, were born in LA.
ALAN SEALES: I want to read
a quote here from the book
because you're talking about
moving to Granada Hills.
"Our neighborhood
was all tract houses
and bordered by orange groves.
At night, the aroma of orange
blossoms was intoxicating.
The first night in the house,
I was awakened by a noise.
I was afraid.
It sounded like the house
was being electrocuted.
I went over to the window,
the sound grew louder.
I opened the window and
it still got louder.
Then I realized what it was.
The sound of a million crickets
had replaced the screaming,
sirens, and gunshots.
I'll make that
trade every time."
CHEECH MARIN: Boy.
Really, it was--
I was a kid in South Central.
It was a very
violent neighborhood.
And there was a lot of
shootings, a lot of killings.
I saw two homicides
right in front of my eyes
before I was seven years old.
Kids that grow up in
that neighborhood--
it was predominantly black,
about 90%, some Mexicans,
a couple of Asians, and one
lost white guy wandering--
ALAN SEALES: With a big camera.
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
And it was a tough neighborhood.
So there was always
that tension.
So people in those
neighborhoods always
grew up with early onset heart
attacks, stroke, hypertension.
It's tense in those
neighborhoods.
So still to this day, the
sound of sirens freak me out.
I look for someplace
to hide because--
ALAN SEALES: Is that why
we had to drag you out
of the green room here?
CHEECH MARIN:
That's actually why.
ALAN SEALES: It's New York, man.
Sirens.
CHEECH MARIN: So we
moved from there,
from South Central to
Granada Hills, which
was a suburb of the San Fernando
Valley, which was primarily
orange groves.
It was an agricultural
neighborhood
that they were converting
to housing tracts.
And so one day
everybody was black,
and then the next day
everybody was white.
And it was like,
how does this work?
Where is the black people?
There's no black people.
How come there's no
black people here?
So it was interesting
to make that change.
ALAN SEALES: So in
the book, though, you
talk about-- you
make little comments
like what you just said.
There's a lot of
mentions about race.
How did that affect, I
guess, who you are now
and what you brought
into your acts
later on, like the racial--
or lack of racial
diversity, I guess?
CHEECH MARIN: The black
culture and neighborhoods
and aesthetic informed a
great part of what we did,
Tommy Chong and I. Because he
came from a black background,
too, because he was born
in Calgary, Alberta.
And he found the one black
neighborhood in Calgary.
It was called Amber Valley.
And his wife came from there.
But he was a musician playing
R&B from a very early age.
ALAN SEALES: He
wrote for Diana Ross.
CHEECH MARIN: He wrote for
Diana Ross and The Supremes.
And so his musical education
was primarily R&B and jazz.
And my musical
education was primarily
from South Central, R&B--
same thing-- then jazz.
So we understood each other
really well in those terms,
in musical terms.
We always viewed Cheech &
Chong in terms of music.
Comedy in terms of music because
it was a rhythmic thing for us.
And it had a rhythm
and it had a beat.
And we knew when to come
in and when to stay out.
And so when we first came to
LA from Canada, all we played
was black clubs in LA.
There was a big
network of black clubs,
and they had the old format.
They had a professional
emcee, who introduced
a professional comedian.
And then the comedians would
introduce the floor show.
And we played in
all the clubs in LA.
And finally, we
made it to the top,
playing this club called
PJ's in Hollywood.
It was the uptown black
club in Hollywood.
And we opened for everybody.
We were the house comedians.
We opened for everybody--
Ray Charles, Carmen
McRae, The Isley Brothers,
The Impressions.
And one night, even
Marvin Gaye got up
and sang "What's Going On"
right when it was first out.
So we were right in
the heart of that.
And that always informed--
and it spilled over
into our comedy.
We had a black rhythm
and a big black audience
that maintains itself to
this day in our following.
ALAN SEALES: Really?
We have a lot to talk
about with Cheech & Chong,
but I want to go back real
quick to when you were younger.
That you actually were in
Catholic school in high school,
right?
CHEECH MARIN: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: And you
were an altar boy?
CHEECH MARIN: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: So obviously,
the weed smoking, and the pot,
and the Catholic
stuff go hand in hand.
CHEECH MARIN: Exactly.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
CHEECH MARIN: Well,
funny thing is it did.
That's the first time
I really understood
what the mass was about.
I went to Easter Sunday--
I'm not kidding.
I went to Easter Sunday,
high mass, candles, incense,
blah blah, blah.
And I smoked a little
weed before I went there.
Oh, I get it.
It's a multimedia experience.
There was this ceremony, a
ritualistic ceremony going on,
transubstantiation,
and the priests.
And everybody was dressed
in their garments.
And oh, I get it.
You're supposed to be
assaulted in order to create
this religious experience.
ALAN SEALES: So--
[LAUGHTER]
Let's let that sit for a second.
CHEECH MARIN: Why do
you think they have it?
ALAN SEALES: In high
school, too, you
said that you were every
teacher's worst nightmare,
because you got straight A's
but were the class clown.
CHEECH MARIN: I was
a pain in the ass.
I was a wise-ass
that never shut up.
And that was always my trouble.
I was always getting in trouble.
I wasn't a malicious
kid or got in trouble,
but I couldn't shut up.
So I thought,
well, maybe there's
show business in my future.
So I was always in trouble,
but I was a straight-A student.
And I would fuck with them
as much as I possibly could.
ALAN SEALES: What would you do?
CHEECH MARIN: The
thing they don't
want you to do in Catholic
school is answer them back.
That's the thing they don't
want because they teach you--
and this is the
philosophy they--
Catholic education
teaches you how to think.
Just don't think that.
It's like, wait a minute.
How do you figure out if God
can do this, then what do you--
and they didn't
like that at all.
You were supposed
to fall in line.
But it was a good
liberal arts education,
which I highly value.
ALAN SEALES: And
most of your family--
or some of your family
went into the priesthood
or went into religion?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
I have two cousins that became
priests and another cousin that
became a nun.
And I was scheduled
to go to the seminary.
And I discovered girls and
went, let me get this straight--
no girls in the priesthood?
I don't think so.
ALAN SEALES: And then
you went to college?
CHEECH MARIN: I did.
ALAN SEALES: Went to college.
And we're talking about pot.
You know, a quote from the
book, "what else have they
been lying about?"
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
That was my first reaction
when I smoked my first joint.
I don't know.
I was a straight kid.
And I was at a party and
somebody handed me a joint.
I'm in college and took
a hit and I got high.
And I looked around, wow.
What else have they
been lying about?
Because this is not at all what
they've been warning me about.
ALAN SEALES: And then this
was also the hippie revolution
happening at the same time.
You also got into
transcendental meditation?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
Very early.
I was pre-Beatles.
And that was the demarcation
there, pre-Beatles,
post-Beatles.
And once again, a
girl led me into that.
My girlfriend, I'm
going to go meditate.
Want to come?
Sure.
And I learned how to
meditate transcendentally.
And I still do that to this day.
ALAN SEALES: Did you
realize in college
that you were actually--
that you already were a hippie?
Or did college-- you looked
around and you're like,
oh, I want to be
like those guys?
CHEECH MARIN: You know, it
was a gradual transformation
because it was happening to
all of us at the same time.
And I was the oldest
of the baby boomers.
The baby boomers started
the year that I was born.
And we started changing
because we started--
it was the worst thing
that they could do,
educate all these guys.
And they asked questions.
And they didn't
like the answers.
And so, wait a minute.
What about this-- why Vietnam?
Where is Vietnam?
What does it represent?
They didn't attack us.
They didn't topple
the Twin Towers.
They didn't bomb
our Pearl Harbor.
They didn't invade us.
And I don't even
know where it is.
Or why are we there?
And they expected everybody
to fall in lockstep conformity
to that.
And there was a college
educated generation
with a lot of people
backing them up
that started questioning and
they didn't like the answers.
ALAN SEALES: And you
were part of a movement
to actually resist the draft?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
It was actually called the
Draft Resistance Movement.
It was headed by David
Harris, who promulgated this,
and he was married to Joan
Baez during the course of this.
So they became this famous,
hippie, anti-war couple.
And they traveled to campuses.
And that's where I
heard David Harris speak
for the first time.
And they just made
the most sense.
The philosophy behind the
Draft Resistance Movement
was to not cooperate.
It was if you're 18, don't
register for the draft.
If you've registered
for the draft,
don't go to the physical.
If you get drafted,
don't show up for--
don't be drafted.
And it goes on--
to clog the bureaucracy.
And that's what it did.
Because traditionally
in history,
if you look back at--
especially here in New York,
any time they
institute a draft, it's
a real division among society.
Because sometimes you can
pay to get out of the draft.
Sometimes you can do crazy
things to get out of the draft.
But it's like-- because they
can arbitrarily grab you,
put you in the army,
and you can get killed.
And it tends to change people's
thinking at that point.
It's not some vague
philosophical concept.
You know, they can grab
you, send you thousands
of miles away into the jungle.
Why am I here?
Boink.
And it made everybody think.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
And what did you do to
your draft card, though?
CHEECH MARIN: Well, first, I
got it signed by Muhammad Ali.
We went to this big
anti-war demonstration
in Century City in Los Angeles.
It was the big one.
President Johnson
was the guy and he
was speaking in Century City.
And there was this big anti-war
draft rally in Rancho Park
right next to it.
And so Muhammad Ali shows up.
And he had just won the world
heavyweight championship
beating Sonny Liston,
the unbeatable.
And he was this young guy.
And at the same time, he
came out as a black Muslim.
He was already, but
he hadn't announced it
until he won the championship.
And he shows up.
And he was the most physically
impressive human being
I've ever seen.
And he's big.
He's like 6' 4",
somewhere around there.
And he was young.
And he was like chiseled.
He was really good looking.
Even in a black suit with a
bow tie, this guy was a star.
You could tell.
He was extremely charismatic,
extremely accessible.
And he started
giving his speech.
And then after,
everybody crowded around
and he was signing autographs.
So I handed him my draft card.
"M. Ali."
Real legible, too.
And so then I took that draft
card and I turned it in.
And it went on a
collage that accompanied
David Harris and Joan
Baez on a speaking
tour around the country.
And you could actually see it.
It was on the cover of
"Newsweek" magazine.
And if you looked
at the collage,
then right in the corner
you could see my draft card
with M. Ali on it.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
You ripped up your
draft card, though.
CHEECH MARIN: Well, that--
ALAN SEALES: Because
that prompted the escape?
CHEECH MARIN: No.
I ripped up my registration
card not my actual draft card.
Because there was an
actual turn-in day
you turned in your draft card.
And the director of the draft
at that time, General Hershey,
issued this directive that
anybody who protested,
caused commotion at
the draft center,
burned their draft card--
I did all those things--
and they would immediately
be reclassified from their 2S
student deferment to 1A,
would be drafted and sent
to the front lines in Vietnam.
That was his fix.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
CHEECH MARIN: Everybody
thought it was bullshit
and it would be overturned.
It was basic First Amendment.
And it was eventually
overturned.
It went to the Court of Appeals.
But you're going to spend three
years, maybe four in the can.
They were sentencing
the draft resisters
to eight years in
Leavenworth at that time.
Coincidentally, in my
last semester in school,
I discovered pottery.
I took a pottery class.
The last semester in
school, you always--
ALAN SEALES: Which
is also for a girl?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
It was also for a girl.
It's always for a girl.
I took all the classes
that I had been putting off
for four years.
You know, Econ
101, and all that.
I only had one spot left over.
And there was this
really cute girl
that I had a class
with previously.
And I says, well,
what are you taking?
She says, I'm taking pottery.
You should take it with me.
I should take it with you.
And so I started making pottery.
And as soon as my hands
touched that clay,
and I centered my
first wad of clay--
[HUMS]
It was like a tuning
fork went off,
and my Mexican genes
came busting out.
Hey, homes, where you been?
We've been waiting for you.
Come on.
Let's make some pots.
And it changed my life.
Really, it changed my life.
I quit my job.
I quit my classes.
I got a $900 NEDA loan, and
I made pottery from sunup
to sundown.
So at the same time, the draft
was kind of hovering over me.
And my pottery teacher, who
kind of knew of my predicament,
he said, I have
this ex-student that
has a pottery up in Canada.
And he's very famous, and
he just won the Bicentennial
Exhibition Award.
He's a big deal.
I'm going to write him and see
if you can be his assistant.
I didn't even wait
for an answer.
I got on the
Greyhound-- and boom.
Next thing, I was in Calgary
and working for this man named
Ed Drahanchuk.
It was great.
ALAN SEALES: And you were
out in the middle of nowhere?
CHEECH MARIN: Nowhere.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
I forget what you said in
the book, the statistic.
It was the first
winter they've had
in like 80 years where a whole
week was below 60 degrees--
negative 60 degrees.
CHEECH MARIN: Just about.
It was the coldest winter
in 80 years in Calgary.
And the high in
January was 20 below.
It was always 40 below.
They got into 50.
And then one night, 75 below.
ALAN SEALES: And there was no
running water in your cabin?
CHEECH MARIN: Nothing.
You had to go to
the river every day
with my little wagon
with my 20-gallon jug.
Go to the river and get water
and then chop wood every day.
And I was from South Central.
I had never seen
snow in my life,
much less go to the river
for my water and chop wood.
And there was a lot
of wildlife around.
There was a lot of bears around.
And I lived in this
little log cabin.
It had electricity,
but that's it--
and a potbelly stove
and an outhouse.
And so I'd always try
to take a crap at work.
They had a flush toilet.
Because in the
middle of the night,
you got to go out to this
outhouse at 40 below,
sit on a wooden toilet
seat with bears around.
And I had a shotgun.
I had a shotgun I would
take with me every time.
It's a little hard to relax--
ALAN SEALES: You left
that bit out of the book.
CHEECH MARIN: --in
that situation.
I just want to dump
and get out of there.
Welcome to the wilderness.
ALAN SEALES: I know I
keep talking about this.
I'll move on, but I find
it just fascinating.
You've told a story, too,
about shooting-- what was it--
a moose in the middle
of that lake, and then
having to chop it up with--
or chop it up with a chainsaw
to take it out of the lake.
CHEECH MARIN: The guy I
worked for, Ed Drahanchuk,
he was of Ukrainian descent.
He was a hunter, avid hunter,
went hunting all the time.
And he was this great potter.
I'd never fired
a gun in my life,
even though my father was a
policeman for 30 years, LAPD.
And so he said, come on.
We're going to go hunting.
I'm going to show
you how to hunt.
OK, great.
And we'd go hunting.
He says, there's a
moose in this area.
I know there is.
I heard that there was.
So we went hunting this moose.
And we worked all day
trying to find him.
Almost to dark and
we find this moose.
It was standing in the
middle of a muskeg.
A muskeg is like a little,
shallow, frozen lake
with a big crust of ice on it.
And so he says, all right.
You go to the other
end of the lake
and try to scare him towards me.
When he comes out,
I'll shoot him.
OK.
What do you want me
to do, make faces?
And so I went out.
And I tried to hey,
come on, moose.
Because I didn't want
him to charge me.
And so after a
while, he wasn't--
[CHOMPING]
And he stood there in
the middle of this lake.
It's not working.
So Ed signaled me to come back.
And I came back.
And then it's starting to get
dark and there's bears out.
I get a little nervous.
And so he says, well, I'm
going to have to drop him
right here, which he did.
He shot this-- moose
goes [CRASHING SOUND].
OK, let's go get him.
And the moose
weighs 1,500 pounds,
so we both grabbed a leg.
We have to go back to the truck.
Yeah, let's get out of here
because this ain't working.
No, no.
We got to go get the saw.
And he goes back.
He has a little chainsaw.
We had to go back and cut
this moose into four quarters.
And then pick it up, hook
it up to like a plow.
What do they call those?
We were in yoke, you know?
And we hooked it up and
dragged these quarters out.
They were frozen.
And you're going through this
like crunch, crunch, crunch,
crunch.
And now it's dark.
But we got him out, and so had
moose meat for a long time.
ALAN SEALES: So then
fast forward a little bit
to getting to Vancouver and
you get to meet Tommy Chong.
What happened there?
How did you meet him?
And what was that like?
CHEECH MARIN: Well, eventually,
I made it to Vancouver.
And I was delivering carpets and
writing for this rock and roll
magazine called "Pop," and
it was a music scene magazine
in Vancouver.
And the editor said, you
know, I got this guy I know.
You should meet him.
He's running this real weird
kind of thing in Chinatown.
What kind of thing?
Is it an opium den with girls?
No.
He says, he's running an
improvisational theater company
in a topless bar
in like the worst
part of town-- in junkie,
wino-ville, Skid Row downtown
Vancouver.
I says, well, some of
it sounds intriguing.
And so he had me meet Tommy
out in this farmhouse.
And Tommy Chong at that
time had really long hair
for the day-- it
was really long--
and a scraggly beard and leather
pants and a jailhouse tattoo.
And he's half-Chinese
and half-English Irish.
And he looked at me
and I looked at him.
We both had the same thought,
what in the hell are you?
Are you Mongolian?
Biker?
Because he had never
seen a Mexican before.
And he's thinking the same.
Are you Filipino?
And so we got together.
And he was running this--
he was with Motown
with Bobby Taylor
and The Vancouvers, his group
that he wrote the hit song for.
And during that period
of traveling around,
he had seen
improvisational theater.
He'd seen Second City
and The Committee.
And he got intrigued.
And even though he never
said a word on stage,
he just played
guitar, he decided
after he split with
the band that that's
what he wanted to do.
ALAN SEALES: Was improv?
CHEECH MARIN: Improv.
And he had a venue when
he got back to Vancouver.
His parents had
turned his last club
into Vancouver's
first topless club.
And so he had this idea.
And he was working the lights
when he first got back,
just to have something to do.
And he kept seeing these girls
come in that were the dancers.
And they were so sexy in their
bell-bottom, low-cut jeans
and their crop tops.
But once they got into
their stripper gear,
they weren't so sexy.
And the guys wouldn't
even look at them.
They were there to drink.
And it was like a tough crowd--
loggers, bikers, prostitutes,
pimps.
Because it was hooker central,
and they ran their office out
of the club--
ALAN SEALES: Like you do.
CHEECH MARIN: Johns and liquor.
It worked really well.
And so he had this
bright idea that he
would have the girls
start off fully clothed
and be involved in some
kind of little skit.
You know, like jokes
out of "Playboy."
Guy walks in.
And he found that
during the course
of the skit, that the
girls would start to strip,
the audience was intrigued.
Because before when
the girls would
stand dancing
naked on the stage,
the guys wouldn't
even look at them.
They were like, [GRUMBLING].
And once the voyeuristic
element of it--
like the girls [MUMBLING].
You could hear a pin
drop in the place.
And so he says,
I'm onto something.
So he started writing
these little skits.
And he had a couple-- there
was four topless dancers,
a mime artist--
I swear to God--
full white face.
ALAN SEALES: Did the mime strip?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
At the strip bar.
No, he didn't.
But--
ALAN SEALES: Oh, OK.
CHEECH MARIN: --we'd
like to do it.
A mime artist, a
classical guitarist,
and four topless
girls, and then me
and Tommy and a couple other
guys for this audience that
didn't want to see us.
They didn't want to see
long-haired guys talking
to them.
They wanted to see naked girls.
It was fabulous.
ALAN SEALES: You said you ended
up inventing hippie burlesque?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah,
that's basically
what it was, because it was
strippers with comedians.
And that's classic burlesque.
That's where all the
old-style comedians--
Phil Silvers and
all those guys--
came out of.
And so we started doing it
but for the hippie generation.
And we started
taking things that
were happening on the street.
I got hired as a
writer, primarily.
And so I go, I can
write for this stuff.
I know what I'm
talking about here.
And so I started writing skits
for them and then filling
in whenever anybody didn't--
and so we kept this.
And it was great.
I mean, it was fabulous.
We did four hours of
improv six nights a week.
So when we came
out of there, man.
We had chops a go-go.
We had a lot of stage experience
with a very hostile audience.
They tried to beat
us up all the time.
The guys would get drunk.
What the hell is this?
And they'd climb on
stage and try to kill us.
Luckily, Tommy had
his brother, Stan,
who was actually a
killer, and his buddies.
And they stood at
the end of the stage.
And Stan was such a thug.
I'll give you a story.
He kept complaining
his knuckle hurt.
My knuckle hurts.
[MUMBLING] And he kept
bitching and bitching.
Tommy says, why don't
you go to the doctor?
Get it checked out.
I'll pay for it.
And so OK.
He goes to the doctor.
The doctor examines
and says, well,
you have a tooth in
your knuckle here.
He had smacked some guy
and the tooth was still
in his knuckle a week later.
So that was kind of the milieu.
If a strip club can have
a milieu, that was it.
ALAN SEALES: And
so at this time,
you were still
Richard and Tommy.
When did Cheech & Chong develop?
When did that happen?
CHEECH MARIN: After
our very first gig.
Because we were both
musicians all our life
and singers and guitar players.
And after the troop broke up--
because the rest of the troop
wanted to go to the hills
to get their heads together.
That's what you
did in those days.
And we had been to the hills
and our head was together.
Our pocketbook wasn't together.
And so we wanted
to form this group.
I said, look, we'll form a
band, and we'll do music,
and we'll do skits.
You're a singer.
I'm a guitar player.
We'll do skits that we've
been developing and music.
And maybe we can
play Vegas one day.
Wow.
That's great.
And so we started.
Our first gig was a battle
of the bands at The Gardens
Auditorium in Vancouver.
And we got up and the band
was on there ready to play.
And we came out and
started doing skits.
And it was really
amazing because this
was a young hippie audience,
or hippie-esque audience.
And they had never
seen us before.
They weren't going to
come down to that club.
There was no way they
were getting anybody--
and that audience was going
to come down to that club
and see us.
So we were really new to them.
And they were intrigued.
We were speaking to them, only
they had never heard us before.
We were them.
And so they were intrigued.
And they jammed to
the front of the stage
and they gathered around.
They went nuts.
And we won the battle of the
bands without playing a note.
ALAN SEALES: And the rest
of the bands just sat there.
CHEECH MARIN: OK.
Now?
OK.
And so we won.
And so the guitar
player asked us,
so when's our next gig, boss?
I don't know if there's
going to be a next gig.
And so we realized
that we were a duo.
We could make it as a duo.
So on the way home
that night we were
in Papa Chong's
car, Tommy's Dad,
and it rains in
Vancouver all the time.
His car didn't have
windshield wipers that worked.
It had windshield wipers.
They didn't work.
He had a wire coat
hanger straightened out
and it went out of the car
and attached to the wiper.
And you-- manually by hand.
And we're trying
to think of a name.
And we're going over
the Georgia Viaduct
Bridge, which was condemned.
There's a big sign,
proceed at your own risk.
It's condemned.
We're going to get it,
but we don't know when.
OK.
So like, hey.
We're going to be big, man.
You hear that reaction?
Yeah, we're going to be good.
We need a new name.
Because it was billed as Tommy
Chong and the Shanghai Junk,
because he had always been in
groups where his name was--
he was Little Daddy
and The Bachelors.
He was the bachelor.
He was Bobby Taylor
and The Vancouvers.
He was a Vancouver.
And he said, the
next thing I'm in I'm
going to have my name in it
so they can't replace me.
Smart.
ALAN SEALES: That's a good plan.
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
And so I said, yeah, me, too.
I don't want to get replaced.
Richard and Tommy?
Nah.
Marin and Chong.
Chong and Marin.
No.
And so he says, do
you have a nickname?
I says, well, Cheech
is my nickname.
It's short for chicharron.
And he said-- all
the Mexicans laugh.
And he says, Cheech?
Cheech.
Cheech and Chong.
And that was it.
Because we were
musicians, we recognized
that that name scanned.
There was a beat to it.
If you said Chong
and Cheech, it--
ALAN SEALES: It doesn't
roll out as well.
CHEECH MARIN: It's
4 or 4 and 1/2 time,
and you just want it to be 4, 4.
It was always Cheech and Chong.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So how much of your act--
I guess how much of
your material, which
has to do a lot with the
pot-smoking characters
and whatnot, how much of that
is actually the two of you
normally versus your
own personal advocacy?
CHEECH MARIN: Well, Tommy
used to say that that was us
when our wives weren't around.
And pretty much, it was true.
We were reflecting what we
saw on the streets and all
the characters we
were running into.
We didn't smoke a
whole lot of dope,
as much as anybody in that era.
But we were hard working trying
to get this act together.
And that's all we
worked on all the time.
And so it was like--
but we came up with
these personas.
And not even the
Cheech character
was fully formed in
Vancouver because they
didn't have a lot of
low-riders in Vancouver.
So it wasn't until we
got back to the States.
And so we decided, well, if
we're going to make it big,
we've got to go to
either New York or LA.
And I says, I heard
it snows in New York,
so I'm not going there
because I've had enough snow.
I was from LA,
and I knew people.
The fly in the ointment was
that I was wanted by the FBI.
ALAN SEALES: For
the draft dodging?
CHEECH MARIN: For
the draft dodging.
It was draft resistance.
They knew I was there.
I wasn't dodging anybody.
And it's funny.
Because it was in the
days before computers,
so their information system's
flow, whatever that's called,
was non-existent.
And so I got in.
I was wanted, but I got in using
a phony ID of my friend Bill
Knorr with his picture on it.
I presented it to the guard.
Hey, that's me.
It looks brown.
Brown.
OK, go ahead.
And I came back to the US.
Although, I was wanted for
a long time when I was back.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
CHEECH MARIN: And
Tommy thought it
was really funny if he mentioned
that all the time on stage.
ALAN SEALES: He
kept pointing out
that you were here illegally?
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
Hey, he's wanted by the FBI.
I said, will you shut
the fuck up, man?
That shit ain't funny.
ALAN SEALES: So you
came back to LA.
You guys were not
really a comedy act,
not really a musical
act, but then you
got signed to a record label.
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: And were the first
comedians on FM radio, yeah?
CHEECH MARIN: Pretty much.
I mean, it was like
everything was in flux.
There was huge changes
going on in the country,
and things that
were nontraditional
could find root and grow.
And we were one of them.
And we'd go around and we'd
hunt for gigs all the time.
And we only had one
goal every day--
was to somehow get
our hands on $1.50.
And for $1.50, we could
make some Chinese meal--
rice and beef and
greens or something.
And we could eat and not starve.
Always walking around, we'd
walk around neighborhoods
and look for clubs or anything.
Anything.
They have a school here.
We can perform in the
quadrangle just to be on stage--
and mostly black clubs.
And it was really, really great.
We had a giant audience
in the black neighborhood.
But on the off-hours, we'd
play these white clubs
that didn't pay money.
But it was exposure.
So eventually, we got discovered
at the Troubadour, which is
the club of note in that day.
That whole singer/songwriter,
Eagles, Linda Ronstadt,
JD Souther, they were all there,
and they got discovered there.
And so we started playing these
hoot nights on Monday, open mic
night, basically.
And we started attracting
an audience and a following.
And then one night,
although the thing
was set up for these producers
at Warner Brothers Records,
Lou Adler, this famous record
producer, was in the audience.
Coincidentally, Lou Adler
had grown up in East LA,
and he knew about Chicano
low-rider culture.
And he immediately recognized
what we were doing.
And he sent word through
this girl that said,
Lou Adler saw you and he
wants you to give him a call.
And Tommy had no idea
who Lou Adler was.
I mean, he was the
biggest record producer
in the world at the time.
He had produced Sam Cook,
Johnny Rivers, Spirit,
The Mamas and Papas,
founded Monterey Pop.
And he was just about to release
"Tapestry" by Carole King.
He was a big deal.
So we called him up.
We went to his
office the next day.
And he looked at us.
He says, well, what
do you want to do?
And we looked around
his office, and it's
covered in gold records.
It was gold records everywhere.
And I says, well,
I'll make a record.
We want to make a record.
Well, what kind?
Gold.
Seems to me that's
what you make,
so we would like to
make a gold record.
And so he signed us to a deal.
Not much money, but enough
to keep us off of starvation.
And so we started working
on how to convert what we
were doing onstage to record.
And we had no idea how
to do that because we
were a visual act.
And so through a process
that we invented ourselves,
we realized that you had to
make things that sounded funny.
Not that looked funny,
but that sounded funny
because they had to
translate by ear.
And you quickly learned that
some knife sounds funnier
than others.
Because we did all
our own sound effects.
And so we started this
process in the studio.
And unlike our
contemporaries, like
Richard Pryor, or Lily Tomlin,
or George Carlin, or Steve
Martin, whose record act
consisted of a live recording
of their stage act.
It was a soundtrack.
You'd hear everybody laughing.
You knew when to laugh.
We started creating these scenes
in the studio with characters
with a lot of sound effects
and a lot of atmosphere
because we were influenced
by other people who
came before us--
notably Ken Nordine,
this guy that
came out in the early '60s.
And we started creating these
things, and they took hold.
And when they got
released, it was
perfect for the
album-listening generation
because albums were starting
to be the big thing.
It was the big
explosion of albums.
And the kids wanted albums.
And FM radio was the
only place that you
could go to hear albums.
It wasn't Top 40-- yummy, yummy,
yummy, I got love in my tummy.
You know, it was like
[MIMICS WHOOSHING SOUND].
These weird sounds.
You could get away
with it because people
listened with headphones, and
so we catered to that audience.
There's a lot of
panning of jet planes
through the middle of your
head and out the thing.
And guns-- whatever it was.
But we played to that.
And it exploded on FM radio.
ALAN SEALES: Wow
So we're actually
a little bit short on time.
If anybody has questions,
step up to the mics here.
But you basically said that
you went from pretty much being
dirt broke to having
over $1 million
in checks sitting on your
counter without a bank account
to put them in, by the
way, within 6 months.
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: You were
on tour that whole time?
CHEECH MARIN: We
were always on tour.
We used to do over 300 nights
a year for eight years,
like always on the road.
And the only way we got off
the road is if one of us
needed an operation
for something.
We used to call it dry dock.
We're going to go into dry dock.
Tommy needs some teeth.
I need a knee.
Really, that's what happened.
So we'd go to dry dock.
And then-- [HEAVY BREATHING].
I remember it like--
the first time we ever
went on a big tour, one
of the first records, we
went on for three months
and never came back.
It was just two guys.
We went all the way across the
country, landed in Montreal,
went to England,
did some time there.
Landed back in the
East and worked our way
all the way back.
And I got home and all I wanted
to do is sit in my living room
and make it stop.
Stop.
This world is going too fast.
It was like I just want to
stay and look out the window.
And my girlfriend at the time
could not-- because I was home.
Let's go out.
Let's go to dinner.
Let's go to this.
Shut up.
And then finally, it did.
And then we would start it--
in a week, we would start
again on a three-month tour.
But the point you brought up
is we would get these checks.
Our album was selling.
It was a big deal.
It started selling, and we would
get a check for like $800,000.
And the next day--
ALAN SEALES: This is the
'70s, so that was still
a lot of money.
I mean, it's a lot
of money anyways.
CHEECH MARIN: That
was the early '70s,
and it was a whole lot of money.
And then the next day we'd get
another check for $700,000.
And we kept getting--
wow.
We didn't know
what to do with it.
Neither one of us had a car.
Really, had no car
or a house because we
didn't need a car on the road.
So finally, we got
time enough to rent
a better apartment or house.
And I kept going on
like that for years.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
So the movies started to happen.
Because you went from radio
to movies, which I think
is probably when
I would describe
a more realistic
conflict started coming
in between you and Tommy.
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
Movies is an
interesting phenomenon--
and the people that work in it--
because it's a dream factory,
and it's myth-making.
And the people that
make the movies
get involved in this
myth of the movies
and their larger-than-life
characters,
and it inflates the
worst parts of you.
And you can be a megalomaniac
or a humble saint
within two seconds of each
other, and it kept fluxing.
And so there was
always a conversation,
a contentious conversation,
between Tommy and I
because we were very strong
personalities-- and two
of them.
But it was the irritant
that produced the pearl.
And we always worked it out.
But as the movies went on, there
was a real division of chores
there.
There's going to be one
person that was the director,
one person is going to be the
writer, one person did that.
As we went along and
got more success,
Tommy wanted to be everything.
He wanted to be the
director or the sole writer.
I said, I just come in?
I say your lines?
Are you out of
your fucking mind?
And so that tension kept
building and building
until we-- he didn't
want me to write anymore.
So we had worked our
way over to we were
living in Paris at the time.
I lived there for a year.
He lived there for three years.
And the last movie came out,
"The Corsican Brothers."
And he stayed in
Paris and I came--
my marriage was falling apart.
And I just didn't want to
do what we were doing .
I didn't want to argue
with him anymore.
I didn't want to fight
And I come back to LA.
And I sat there and smoked dope
and played guitar for as long
as I could.
And then I was
watching TV one day,
and then this
phenomenon happened.
It was MTV.
And it took over music.
And everybody watched
MTV 24 hours a day.
And it was videos.
And I realized that
this is perfect for us.
We were filmmakers.
We were musicians.
We were comedians.
And we could make
these funny videos.
We could put them all
together, have a video album.
It would be great.
We could take over the world.
And I called Tommy in Paris
and I said, I got this deal.
We can do this.
And he wasn't interested.
He said, well-- I told him.
I said, yeah.
We Have MTV over here in France.
You're into video.
I'm into film.
Kiss my ass, mother fucker.
What the fuck, man?
Look, I got this deal.
And let's come over.
You come over.
He says, well, I'll come
over and do a couple of them.
So one of the
ones-- so I'm trying
to write these other
songs and videos.
And I needed one more.
And I was at my kitchen
table in the morning,
and I was having a cup of
coffee, reading the paper,
and the music was playing.
And I was reading this
article about this young kid,
Chicano kid in LA who was
like 12, 13-- around there.
And he was mentally
retarded and he
couldn't communicate
to the-- he got
caught in an immigration raid.
And he couldn't
communicate to the officers
that he was an American
citizen, and they deported him
to Mexico.
And his parents
didn't know where
he was for almost two months.
And they just dumped him
on the streets of Tijuana
and that was it.
And I started-- and Bruce
Springsteen's song comes on,
that song, "Born in the USA."
I kept saying born in East LA.
And that was it.
That was the last song.
So I wrote the song, and
we're going to record it.
We're in the studio.
And I almost had finished it,
but the middle section, which
was for two guys
improving back and forth--
which was our forte.
That's how we always
did everything--
was for Tommy and I. And
he wasn't in the studio.
And I waited and wait.
It was almost 9 o'clock.
I go, what's wrong with him?
So I picked up the phone,
called him, and he was home.
Tommy, did you forget we had
this radio recording date?
He says, no.
You do it, man.
What?
No, no, man.
We've got to do
the middle section.
He says, no.
It's your song.
You do it.
I said, come on, man.
The thing's for us.
And he says, no.
You do it.
It's your thing.
So you're not coming in?
No, you do it.
And I was really sad.
I was really sad, because I
had always been there for him.
And the first time I asked him
to be there for me, and he--
because it was a tug.
It was a battle.
ALAN SEALES: So was
that the definitive end
of Cheech & Chong right
there, I would say?
CHEECH MARIN: Pretty much.
What happened-- and you got
to be careful what you do--
is I went and I
recorded the song.
I played both parts.
The song came out, and
the video came out.
And he wasn't in the song,
so he wasn't in the video.
And both became really big hits.
They were a number 1 song
and a number 1 video.
And the head of the studio
in Columbia, Frank Price,
got turned onto the
video by Irving Azoff,
who was a record producer.
And he called me,
and we had already
made two movies for him.
And he called me and he said,
I think there's a movie here,
but it's for you.
It's not a team movie, because
there's no drugs involved.
And it's for your persona.
If you want to,
there's a movie here.
And I want you to star
in it and write it.
OK.
Tommy and I had a meeting.
He came over ostensibly to pitch
me a story for a TV series.
Before he got started,
I said, look, man.
This is what happened.
I got offered this
movie by Frank Price,
and I'm going to do it.
And it was like, there it was.
And he just got
mad and got shook
and turned around and walked
to his car and that was it.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
So we've only got
a few minutes left.
I've only got through like
half of my notes right here.
CHEECH MARIN: You simply
must buy the book.
It's called "Cheech
is Not My Real Name."
ALAN SEALES: You were friends
with John Lasseter, who
made you the voice of
many of his characters
in Disney and Pixar,
including Tito, the Chihuahua
from "Oliver & Company."
It's one of my favorites.
Can you give us a check it out?
CHEECH MARIN: Check it out.
There was one bit of direction.
George Schrader-- and
he was Panamanian.
This guy, George Schrader,
anyway, spoke perfect Spanish.
And I went into like--
I was looking for
a gig to do after.
And I got this call to come in
and audition for this thing.
And I went in there, and
I didn't know how to--
I had never had an audition
for anything, ever.
I did the text that they have.
And everybody goes,
oh, that's very nice.
And I got in the parking lot.
I said, that sucked.
So I went back in.
I said, what I did, it sucked.
I want to do it again.
They go, OK.
And so George gave me
one bit of direction.
He says, play this character,
Tito, which was a chihuahua,
like you have one finger
in a light socket.
That's all I needed--
at the top of my voice.
And it was a breakout character.
And the movie became a big hit.
And then I started on this
road of animated movies.
And it was what I was
born to do or was trained
to do more than anything,
because animation was Cheech
& Chong without the animation.
It was voice acting, and
I knew how to do that.
So a string of movies--
"The Lion King," "Cars."
And we're still doing
"Cars" right now.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, right.
I mean, there's
so much about you.
CHEECH MARIN: These
guys got nothing to do.
They can go in the
little cubbyholes,
and order free food, and
lay back, and watch TV.
This is much more
informative, right?
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
There's so much I want to cover
and we don't have time for.
So you've been a cub scout,
Boy Scout, altar boy,
guitar player, potter--
everything.
You've danced with
Kate Middleton.
And now, you're the owner--
CHEECH MARIN: She asked me.
ALAN SEALES: You
are the largest--
you're the owner of the
largest Chicano art collection.
CHEECH MARIN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Right?
CHEECH MARIN: In the
known hemisphere.
ALAN SEALES: Are there
any unknown hemispheres?
CHEECH MARIN: Well, sure.
ALAN SEALES: And now, I want
to give you a quick plug
before we wrap up here.
So what is this?
CHEECH MARIN: This is a bottle.
It's a concept in
Western civilization.
This is my new line of mezcal
called Tres Papalote, which
means Three Kites.
So you can get higher than
three kites on this thing.
And as I said, a company
came to me and says,
we'd like you to be involved
in the beverage industry.
And how about some wine?
I said, well, I'll drink it, but
I don't know anything about it.
And they say, well,
you're Mexican.
How about some tequila?
So I said--
ALAN SEALES: Thanks, asshole.
CHEECH MARIN: OK.
There's a zillion
tequilas out there.
And so I said, well,
you know what's
an undiscovered
category is mezcal.
And so why don't we do a mezcal.
What's that?
That's the one with the
worm in it, isn't it?
No, no.
It's mezcal, and it's a very
distinct, artisanal beverage.
And so we started investigating.
And we thought, hey,
this is a coming thing,
and it's really good.
It's something new to drink that
has a distinctive smoky taste.
And it's like tequila.
I call it tequila with tattoos.
And now it's catching on.
There's mezcal bars everywhere,
and it's the hipster thing
to do.
And millennials love
it, and I love it.
And it's a great
drink to drink--
ALAN SEALES: Millennials.
CHEECH MARIN: Millennials, yeah.
That's the new term.
ALAN SEALES: Which is
now like the largest
consumer of boxed wine as well.
CHEECH MARIN: Yes, exactly.
Here's a little fact--
84% of all wine is drunk 48
hours after its purchase.
All wine.
That's why they don't
have corks anymore.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Don't need them.
CHEECH MARIN: Don't need them.
These 50-year-old
Cabernets, that's
like that much of the market.
48 hours, 84% of all wine.
So anyways, we started.
We put this out.
It has been highly successful.
And this is one of the figures
from my Chicano art collection.
It's a glass statue by
the De La Torre Brothers.
And I'm trying to
get them jobs, too,
because Mexicans
help each other.
And they're all related.
And I think-- do we
have some for them?
No.
No, you get to look at it.
And it's a great, great
drink, Tres Papalote.
I wish we had some art books.
We didn't bring any
art books with us.
ALAN SEALES: No.
Not this time.
CHEECH MARIN: We're trying
to get rid of them, too.
ALAN SEALES: Oh.
Ship them over.
We'll give them out.
CHEECH MARIN: I
just might do that.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
CHEECH MARIN: All right.
ALAN SEALES: Sorry, go ahead.
CHEECH MARIN: Go ahead.
No.
ALAN SEALES: I was
going to wrap up.
I want you to continue
your story, though.
CHEECH MARIN: As things
come into your screen,
you go, oh, I could be involved.
You guys are going to be
the first to know about it.
I'm coming out with
my own weed line
called Cheech's Private Stash.
It'll be available wherever fine
weed is sold, mostly online.
No, but-- I mean,
millennials like it.
ALAN SEALES: Did you know
that most weed is smoked
24 hours after purchasing?
CHEECH MARIN: That is true.
It's an interesting
thing because we're
waiting to see where
the government was going
to come down with Trump and--
Mr. Peanut.
And are they going
to go buy these--
but even Sessions
is not dumb enough
to go up against 33 states.
And he's a states'
rights advocate.
I mean, like you can't have
states' rights for some things
and not states' rights
for other things.
And so now what they
indicate is we're just
going to leave the marijuana
thing, because there is going
to be a lot of pushback from the
other side who are well-funded
and the states who get
$200 to $300 million
in taxes for their
beleaguered states every year.
And I think it's the intoxicant
of choice of now generations
rather than--
and it has medicinal
qualities for sure.
And I haven't heard any
argument from medical beer yet.
ALAN SEALES: Your
liver is too good.
Have this beer.
CHEECH MARIN: Pickle
it a little bit.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
CHEECH MARIN: And so it was
all these things coming,
and they go with
lifestyle because we're
increasingly involved
in lifestyle, obviously.
And we're figuring out
how the market works.
Because you can only grow
and sell weed in the state
that you're in.
You can't transport
it across state lines
to sell California
weed in Colorado.
And for every state
that has legalized--
some form of legalized weed--
there is an equal
and opposite group
on the other side that wants
to undo all those laws.
And they throw logs in
your path all the time.
But the stain keeps--
it's like a lava flow.
I mean, you can
stand in front of it,
but I wouldn't recommend it.
Because it's going to be--
and it's going to go
across the nation.
The thing that they're
going to find out
is there is people
that smoke marijuana
in every single
stratum of society--
financial, religious, ethnic.
And good luck fighting it.
And I think they kind of
looked over the abyss.
No, I don't think
we're going in there.
So that's happening.
Cheech's Private Stash.
ALAN SEALES: Is there
a website to get more?
CHEECH MARIN: Not yet
but there will be.
ALAN SEALES: We'll add it
to the YouTube description
for this video once you get it.
CHEECH MARIN: Yes, please.
And it's great.
I mean, it has really
medicinal properties.
ALAN SEALES: I think
it's really good.
That's what I'm
taking from this.
CHEECH MARIN: That's it.
I just had a nausea caused
by some stomach problems.
And I was taking all the
prescribed medications,
and it was only weed
that stopped this nausea.
And nausea-- I don't
know if anybody
has had a bout of nausea
here that's ongoing.
It's debilitating.
It really is debilitating.
Because like, you're
just like, oh, man.
I feel like shit.
And weed knocked
it out right away.
And I didn't want to admit
it, because I, you know,
I want to be [MUMBLES].
But you know, it's nice.
ALAN SEALES: What's
next then for you?
You've got something-- your
name on everything under the sun
here.
CHEECH MARIN: Well,
I'm a Chicano.
I have to have three
jobs at all times.
I was raised that way.
My dad always had three jobs.
You got to have three jobs.
OK.
And so I'm going to continue
writing, which I really enjoy.
It Because I was a
writer all my life.
I was an English
major in college.
And I wrote all the time.
So there's a couple of things
that I really want to write.
I'm halfway through a book
of essays about the Latino
experience in the United States.
It's called "We Come in Peace
and We Have You Surrounded."
It's sort of a cautionary tale.
And then I'm reading this
novella called "Hector."
And it's about
this young Chicano
kid who belongs to the
world's smallest minority.
He's a Mexican vegetarian.
Because there aren't
a lot of those.
And the travails
he's going-- there's
sort of magical
realism aspects of it,
because I'm a big Gabriel
Garcia Marquez fan.
If you read this book,
"Cheech is Not My Real Name,"
I meet Gabriel Garcia
Marquez in Havana.
And it was like meeting
Shakespeare for me.
I was like, that's Gabo,
and he's standing there,
and I'm being introduced.
And now he's going
to shake my hand.
Wow.
And he says, hello, really
deeply and then splits.
That's it.
Hello.
[MUMBLES] OK, cool.
But that's the thing
about a celebrity--
you get to meet all the
people that you adore.
And he was one of them.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
Well, I appreciate it so much.
Thank you for coming.
CHEECH MARIN: Thank
you very much.
ALAN SEALES: This
has been wonderful.
CHEECH MARIN: Thanks
for having me.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.
CHEECH MARIN: Thank
you very much.
My pleasure.